these are the five particular moments in
the last year which have made the
biggest impression on me in logging the
progress of this war
the first one was on the second night
after the invasion when president
zielinski went out onto the streets of
Kiev to show the world that he hadn't
run he hadn't gone to the United States
he was there with his cabinet and he
made a speech it only lasted for 40
seconds
he said I'm here we're not going
anywhere we are going to fight and that
message a quick short message out there
on the streets of Kiev gave hope to the
people of Ukraine that they would fight
and they would not be conquered and it
gave the rest of the world something to
latch on to and the Americans said fine
okay you will fight we will do whatever
it takes and that's set up the the fact
that this is a war it's not a conquest
it's a war that the ukrainians have got
some hope of winning at some point
the second moment for me was when the
Great Russian Convoy this Russian Convoy
that was moving down to the west of Kiev
moving slowly then it stopped and we all
wondered what it was going to do and how
it was going to disperse itself to
surround and conquerque of it had been
stationary for some days and then it
started to withdraw and we realized that
actually
um the ukrainians had attacked it very
cleverly they reduced it to immobility
and the Russians own incompetence their
own logistical problems that actually
made the the Convoy unviable and they
withdrew the reason that that moment was
so important is because it showed us
that the Russians had taken on probably
more than they could chew here that they
were not competent at this sort of
operation and that they would have to
learn very quickly
the third moment for me revolved around
Mario poll the city in the South that
should have fallen within the first
hours of the invasion and in fact were
still fighting a couple of months later
and the Russians just bombarded Mario
Paul to Smithereens they just artillery
shelled it to Oblivion until eventually
it was surrounded and the ukrainians had
to withdraw or or Surrender but then the
fight went on and the other style steel
Works underground they would not
surrender and the Russians didn't quite
know how to get them out eventually when
they ran out of food and ammunition they
then surrendered
and a bit later uh though some prisons
were exchanged and some of the prisons
that were exchanged were some of the the
civilian women who were taken and from
the avastal steel works and when they
were released they came walking out from
the buses and they formed up in in ranks
of about six they walked in step with
their heads held high and their message
to the world was we are the women of
avastal and this is Ukraine that was a
big moment it was a big moment I think
because it showed that although Maria
Paul was a defeat it was a defeat that
the ukrainians would take heart from
and then the fourth moment that was the
the day when the ukrainians successfully
attacked the Kersh straight Bridge which
was the pride and joy of Putin and it
broke the land link between Crimea and
Russia proper that was a big moment
because the attack on the Kern Street
Bridge as it would provoked the Russians
into this new and much more destructive
quite barbaric policy of making War
directly on the population of Ukraine
two days later on the 10th of October
the Russians began this new policy of
shelling with missiles and artillery and
using bombs to actually attack the
infrastructure of Ukraine so in other
words they now are trying to take down
the electricity system for the whole of
Ukraine to give the ukrainians a
miserable starving cold winter
and then the fifth moment was the
Russian withdrawal from Kirsten down in
the southwest they'd taken Kirsten it
was the only uh significant City that
the Russians had taken but the
ukrainians built up their attacks around
it they attacked Russian Logistics they
moved against Kirsten in the north and
in the west eventually the Russians had
to withdraw humiliating for Putin they
simply went to the Eastern side of the
river
and that's where they have been since
and so getting Kirsten back was a big
moment and that expresses the fact that
the ukrainians think they can win back
their territory he's at the beginning of
the end of the war they're not just
going to lose slowly and gallantly
they're going to win back as much as
they can and so the narrative for this
second year of the war is Russia's
determination to keep on with these
brutal attacks whatever it takes and
Ukraine's determination to win back
territory and basically throw the
Russians out certainly if all the
territory of the taken since February
and maybe maybe all the territory they
have taken since 2014.